START FROM THERE, WE WERE
GETTING OUT THERE.
WE WERE PREPARED FOR THAT, TOO.
>> SO, YOU START ON THE FIRST
FLOOR, MAKE YOUR WAY UP TO THE
THIRD?
>> WE STARTED ON THE FIRST
FLOOR.
THEY CLEARED THAT.
THERE WAS AT THE END OF A LONG
HALLWAY ON THE FIRST FLOOR WAS A
BARRICADED DOOR, WHICH IS
ANOTHER SIGN THAT SOMEONE
IMPORTANT IS INSIDE.
THE GUYS AHEAD OF ME, THEY USED
THEIR METHODS OF ENTRY, A COUPLE
DIFFERENT ATTEMPTS AND THEY
OPENED IT, AND THEN WE STARTED
GOING UP THE STAIRS FROM THE
FIRST FLOOR TO THE SECOND FLOOR.
ON THE WAY UP, THE ANALYST THAT
TOLD US WE WOULD RUN INTO
KHALEED BIN LADEN, OSAMA BIN
LADEN'S SON, AND SHE SAID IF WE
SEE HIM, HE'S THE LAST LINE OF
DEFENSE.
>> TAKE HIM OUT?
>> WELL, IF HE'S ARMED, AND HE
WAS ARMED, SO HE WAS ELIMINATED,
THE THREAT THERE.
CONTINUED UP TO THE SECOND
FLOOR.
I WAS ABOUT EIGHT GUYS -- THE
EIGHTH GUY BACK, MAYBE?
ONCE WE GOT TO THE SECOND FLOOR,
THE GUYS IN FRONT OF ME, ALL
EXCEPT FOR THE ONE MAN, STARTED
TO CLEAR THE THREATS ON THE
SECOND FLOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO SECURE THAT FLOOR
UNTIL WE MOVE UP.
SO, I MOVE MY WAY UP TO THE
SECOND POSITION BEHIND THE FIRST
MAN, AND HE WAS POINTING UP THE
STAIRS TO THE THIRD FLOOR, AND
THERE WAS A CURTAIN ON THE TOP
OF THE FLOOR AND THERE WAS SOME
MOVEMENT BEHIND IT WITH UNKNOWN
SILHOUETTES.
HE WAS GETTING CONCERNED THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE EXPLOSIVES OR
PUTTING ON VESTS OR THEY'RE
RIGGING SOMETHING AND HE WAS
LETTING ME KNOW -- WELL, LETTING
THE GUY BEHIND HIM KNOW THAT --
IT JUST TURNED OUT TO BE ME --
THAT THERE'S A THREAT AT THE TOP
OF THE STAIRS AND WE NEED TO GO
NOW.
I NEEDED MORE PEOPLE, BUT HE WAS
SPOT ON, SO I GAVE HIM A
SQUEEZE.
WE WENT UP THROUGH THE CURTAIN
AND THE UNKNOWNS TURNED OUT TO
BE SOME FEMALES.
HE SORT OF GRABBED ON TO THEM
AND PUSHED THEM A LITTLE BIT
DOWN THE HALLWAY, FALLING ON
THEM TO ABSORB THE BLAST HE KNEW
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
HE GAVE HIS LIFE SO THE GUY
BEHIND HIM COULD GET A SHOT.
FROM THERE, WHEN HE PUSHED THE
WOMEN, I TURNED TO THE RIGHT
INTO A DOORWAY, AND THE DOORWAY
LED TO A BEDROOM.
AND IN THE BOTTOM WAS OSAMA BIN
LADEN, A MATTER OF FEET IN FRONT
OF ME.
AND HE HAD HIS HANDS ON HIS
WIFE'S SHOULDERS.
HE WAS NOT SURRENDERING.
HE WAS SORT OF MOVING AND JUST
BASED ON THE LEVEL OF THREAT OF
HIM NOT SURRENDERING AND THE
LIKELIHOOD OF HIM HAVING A VEST,
I SHOT HIM TWICE IN THE HEAD.
HE FELL ON THE FLOOR.
I SHOT HIM ONE MORE TIME AND I
KILLED HIM.
>> IN THAT BRIEF MOMENT YOU HAD
WITH HIM, DID YOU GET A SENSE OF
HIM AT ALL?
WAS IT LIKE, THIS IS THE WORLD'S
MOST EVIL MAN?
OR WAS IT, THIS IS A COWARD,
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER GUY?
WHAT DID IT FEEL LIKE?
>> THE SENSE WAS RECOGNITION OF,
FIRST OF ALL, AN I.D. OF HIM AND
HE IS A THREAT.
AND THEN I HAD TO SHOOT HIM.
AND IT WASN'T THE FIRST TIME I
HAD DONE THAT ON A TARGET
BEFORE.
THIS WASN'T THE FIRST TARGET I
HAD BEEN ON.
AT THAT POINT, HE WAS A TARGET.
I RECOGNIZED THE THREAT, I
RECOGNIZED THE INDIVIDUAL WE
WERE AFTER, WHICH WAS OSAMA BIN
LADEN, AND I ENGAGED.
>> A SNIPER FRIEND OF MINE WANTS
TO ASK YOU, WHAT DID IT FEEL
LIKE?
>> AT THAT MINUTE, IT WAS JUST,
IT FELT LIKE THAT WAS THE
FIRST -- THE INITIAL THREAT THAT
I HAD TO TAKE CARE OF, AND THEN
THERE WERE MORE THREATS.
THREATS ARE JUST POTENTIAL
UNKNOWNS.
THERE WERE TWO MORE -- WELL,
THERE WAS A WOMAN AND THEN WAS A
CHILD.
I WANTED TO PUT THEM IN A PLACE
WHERE THEY WERE NOT IN DANGER,
SO THEY WENT ON THE BED AND THEN
OTHER SPOTS HAD TO BE CLEARED.
IT WASN'T UNTIL MORE S.E.A.L.s
WERE IN THE ROOM AND THE ROOM
WAS CLEARED THAT I HAD A MOMENT
OF PAUSE.
AND I TALKED IT A FRIEND OF MINE
IN THE ROOM, AND HE CAME UP TO
ME AND PUT HIS HAND ON MY
SHOULDER, AND I SAID, "HEY, WHAT
DO WE DO NOW?"
AND HE SMILED AND SAID "NOW WE
GO